nos piden resolver 70 menos 50 esto es
igual a 7 decenas menos espacio en
blanco
decenas sabemos que setenta son siete
decenas hay un siete en la posición de
las decenas aquí por eso son siete
decenas menos tenemos que ver cuáles son
las escenas que representa esta cantidad
este 50 nos fijamos que no tiene
unidades y nos fijamos que en la
posición de las decenas hay un 5 por lo
tanto son cinco decenas siete decenas
menos cinco decenas setenta menos
cincuenta es igual a cuantas decenas
pues ya que lo tenemos aquí en decenas
vamos a restar las decenas siete decenas
menos cinco decenas siete menos cinco va
a ser dos por lo que 70 menos 50 va a
ser igual a dos decenas y cuánto es dos
decenas
aquí lo que nos están pidiendo es la
cantidad pero ya no en decenas sino la
cantidad normal por lo que 70 menos 50
quedamos que son dos decenas y cuántos
son dos decenas pues van a ser 20
70 menos 50 es igual a 20 vamos a checar
nuestra respuesta es correcta vamos a
hacer otro problema ahora nos dicen que
hay que restar 90 menos 40 pero primero
lo tenemos que dejar en términos de
decenas 90 menos 40 es igual a 9 decenas
si nos fijamos en esta cantidad éste 9
está en la posición de las decenas
no tenemos unidades aquí hay un cero por
lo que son nueve decenas esto es igual a
esto
- ahora vemos aquí tenemos un 40 el 40
cuántas decenas son pues nos fijamos qué
número hay en la posición de las decenas
y hay un cuatro son cuatro decenas nueve
decenas menos cuatro decenas noventa
menos cuarenta cuántas decenas son
aquí tenemos las escenas nueve decenas
menos cuatro decenas 94 va a ser igual a
55 decenas y ahora nos piden el
resultado 90 menos 40 pero en la
cantidad normal no en deseables cuántos
son cinco decenas una decenas son diez
así que cinco decenas son cincuenta
vamos a achicar nuestra respuesta es
correcta vamos a hacer otro problema más
ahora nos dicen 30 más algo va a ser
igual a 50 vamos a ver qué número
tenemos que agregarle al 30 para que nos
dé 50 bueno si a 30 le agrego 10 van a
ser 40 y si a ese 40 le agrego otros 10
voy a tener 50 cuando le agregue a pues
le agregue 210 es dos decenas es decir
20 30 más 20 es igual a 50 así que 50
menos 30 cuánto va a ser bueno sabemos
que 30 más 20 es igual a 50 ahora a este
50 que es este de aquí le vamos a quitar
30 estos 30 cuánto nos va a dar como
resultado
esta cantidad de aquí la diferencia
entre 30 y 50 es 20 aquí vamos a tener
20 dos decenas comprobamos la respuesta
es correcto